the family of a woman who died inside a
Nevada County Jail says guards ignored
her pleas to be taken to a dr. Kelly
Coltrane was arrested during a routine
traffic stop last year three days later
she died in her cell
vladimir duthiers our streaming network
cbsn shows us why state investigators
believe that her death may have been a
crime that good morning good morning
Kelly Coltrane's agonizing final hours
were captured by surveillance camera and
the images are disturbing she was
suffering painful drug withdrawals but
her family says she might have survived
if guards had followed their departments
own policies Kelly Coltrane spent much
of her final day convulsing and throwing
up in her jail cell surveillance video
shows her being ordered to mop up her
own vomit about an hour later
around 6:30 p.m. she appears to die
there wasn't her pulse taken it wasn't
an aspirin they left her to die attorney
Terry Kaiser Cooper says Coltrane
revealed her drug addiction and history
of seizures and withdrawals to guard
shortly after she was arrested last July
the 27 year old even asked to see a
doctor but a deputy said he told her I'm
not going to take you over to the
hospital right now just to get your fix
the hospital is right across the street
from the jail how long would that take
two minutes to take her over there a
guard checked on Coltrane around 12:30
a.m. by then she was cold and
unresponsive at 5:40 a.m. about 11 hours
after she died her body was finally
removed from the cell a 300-page report
by the Nevada Department of Public
Safety says staff at the Mineral County
Jail disobeyed department policies by
not taking her to a doctor or doing
regular welfare checks they also may
have broken the state law against
inhumanity to prisoners this is the
worst example of deliberate indifference
to a serious medical need that I have
ever seen
Coltrane was initially pulled over for
speeding and then jailed for unpaid
tickets and driving with a suspended
license her family filed a federal
lawsuit last week
accusing jail officials of violating her
civil rights and inflicting cruel and
unusual punishment to officers seen in
the videos were disciplined and are no
longer working at the jail
kills me that she's not ever gonna get
to go home and that she died alone Katie
Andriano says her best friend who
developed her addiction following a
devastating soccer injury in high school
was trying to quit heroin she didn't
want to be a junkie you know she she
wanted to just be a normal person like
you are I a lawyer for the county
refused to comment on Coltrane's case
but told CBS this morning the jail is
committed to providing appropriate
medical care for all detainees
he also said an outside expert has been
hired to audit its policies and provide
training a prosecutor declined to bring
charges in the matter I think everybody
agrees that shouldn't have happened in
jail yeah I'm glad thank you a better
way to handle that